- People are like, trust is earned.
I'm like, cool, that seems
fucking slow and egotistical.
- [Caleb] You give trust
maybe easier than some CEOs?
- I do.
- Why is that?
What's the methodology?
- It's offense, I think
people say no too often.
because they fear ramifications.
I don't think micro losses are scary
and empowering people to make
decisions is how you scale
and to me I've always thought
that somebody doing an 86
instead of my 100 is better
than not doing it at all.
Plus, how ami ever gonna
learn if somebody's capable
without giving them a chance?
Like, eventually you have
to let your kid swim,
eventually you have to
let them swing the bat.
And so yeah, I'm completely
not driven by fear
and people are and the reason
people don't let people
do things is they fear it,
or they have, I mean, it's ego.
A lot of people don't
want their understudies
or their direct reports
of the people they manage
to be better at something than them.
It's just insecurity.
I'm massively secure in myself
and that's exactly right,
Caleb, that's a good insight,
you're doing a good job with this
in asking me these questions.
Like, I say yes, I give trust
at first, you can lose it,
people are like, trust is earned.
I'm like, cool, that seems
fucking slow and egotistical.
Like, who the fuck am I to have it earned.
Like, great, like, fuck that.
To me, trust is given and then you lose it
if you're a dickface,
uncapable, incapable, excuse me,
and have proven that you're
not worthy of the challenge
or the role.
I think one thing I've noticed though
that is a counteract to my
move is that a lot of times
when you accelerate that too
soon people become entitled.
They, in the micro, get a
little bit high on their supply
and they think they're big shit
and they start having egos underneath you
when you were, like, watching my people
that I empower with like,
I trust you blindly,
then not trust people
blindly underneath them
is heartbreaking, happens often,
and is something I'm thinking a lot about.
- [Caleb] How do you communicate
or how do you distill
that same methodology
to the people under you so that they're,
it's like a prolonged process?
- I don't, I prefer to see what people
actually do naturally themselves
than try to micro manage it.
I think a lot of people never
get a true read on somebody
because they've over
manipulated their tasks
and the person is doing
exactly what that boss wants
and to me ultimate
scale is allowing people
to roam free and expose themselves,
it's kind of like that rope, right?
I'll give you a rope
and you can go forever
or you can hang yourself with that rope.
I think that, whatever that
analogy is that I've heard
in culture, I'm sure is what I'm doing
which is I'm giving
unbelievable amounts of rope
and some people will run
into perpetuity with it
and create enormous amounts of happiness
and wealth and success and
whatever we do together
and others will get tripped up on it
and get caught up in their
bungee cord and lose.
(upbeat music)